jenny vance is very well educated and
still very sensible running for senate
in ohio he joins us tonight jenny vance
i know that you are very concerned about
student loan debt any person looks at
the numbers is is this the way to
address it
i know it's certainly not tucker i mean
you hit the nail on the head that this
is effectively a bailout for a super
corrupt educational system the harvard
endowment has 60 billion dollars the
yale endowment has 40 billion dollars if
you want to give student debt relief you
should penalize the people who have
benefited from this very corrupt system
not ask plumbers in ohio to subsidize
the life decisions of of
college-educated young people primarily
young people who are going to make a lot
of money over the course of their
lifetime anyway
so no this is exactly the wrong way to
do it and again if you give this bailout
to these university administrators
they're going to keep doubling down on
what they've done which is effectively
indoctrinating our kids not educating
them not giving them the useful skills
for the job market but indoctrinating
them and getting a massive windfall from
joe biden in the process it's really
really corrupt and it's going to make
that corrupt system live even longer
i just don't understand why republicans
don't say anything about this everybody
understands that students are so
crippled by debt they can't begin adult
lives okay that's a real problem and we
should not deny it but the people who
caused the problem who benefited from
the problem who defrauded these students
are not paying like why is it so hard
for republicans to say hey yale it's
time for you to pay reparations to your
students
not only are they not paying tucker
they're actually being rewarded by this
policy and that's what makes it such a
huge mistake and i got to say tucker
there is a political dimension to this
of course i'm running against tim ryan
democrat from ohio who's been on every
side he's flip-flopped on every side of
the student debt issue but if you think
about this two months before the
election joe biden has given a massive
windfall to democratic party donors it's
one of the reasons why i'd encourage
people to help us fight back at
jdvance.com but this has very direct
implications for the middle class in
this country tucker you know as well as
anybody that if you look behind a lot of
our bad policies whether it's the
student bailouts the globalization
moving stuff to china whatever you want
to say it's very often a massive
transfer of wealth from middle class
hard-working people to the upper class
in this country that's exactly what this
is a massive bailout for people who've
made bad decisions and are doing very
well economically when i say that i mean
the college administrators of course
it's hard to imagine a worse policy a
policy that solves few of our problems
and harms
much more people
and rewards the worst people it really
it really does i appreciate coming on jd
vance thanks so much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight